in regards to the way that critical
theorists view Society is it only racist
if you make fun of a marginalized
Community or is it is it still racist if
you make fun of a non-marginalized
community but it's okay that it's racist
it's not so according to the left it's
not racist if you're punching up yeah
racism is Prejudice plus power it can
only be applied to those who are weaker
than you so I have a white homeless guy
is laying on the ground with no teeth
and he's and he's shivering in the cold
and then you know a marginalized person
walks by him and stumbles on him and the
white homeless guy says hey don't you
stumble on me they're gonna be like whoa
that was racist like how dare you like
because he's white then that was the
matter that he's dying it would make
people try to become victims and
marginalized so that they can protect
themselves from the racist jokes that's
that's the standard Behavior now